good thank you okay thank you for a very
nice introduction well I would like to
thank organizers really for inviting me
because it is a very exciting to be here
and I would like to thank all of you for
the time to be here and speaking about
the time I think that the timing of this
talk is also just about right because
there will be soon coming new release of
the Syfy library and I think that all of
you is here because she would like to
know about the new developments in the
Python word and side by library is one
of the projects which is pretty crucial
for many data scientists around the
world and we have been hosted there
there was a hackathon hosted by AHL
which was very nice
we were working on implementing the
stable laws there has been already some
kind of development done in that area I
am NOT super exciting about the
development which will go into the new
release but partly because I am NOT
excited it is important before you start
to use it to give you a certif
one-on-one stable loss introduction such
that you know what you are going to be
facing and what are the troubles you
might run into because if you learn how
to vary that the large class of the
probability distributions it is pretty
much going to change the possibilities
which you have in the modeling world so
wow it's great it's okay hopefully it is
going to fit well right so you might be
asking what are the state laws and how
it comes that if they are so important
that they haven't been implemented
earlier in a certain way they are not
the celebrated between the probability
distributions because they don't have
the nicest properties on the planet
which people might like in order to use
them very efficiently but they have lots
of nice properties and
thanks to the computational power which
we have in these days I think that it is
just about rights time to really start
to work with them so if I start with
some motivation I'm really quite
surprised that it actually doesn't fit
properly the slides but I will be sort
of moving it around so if I start with
some motivation why not to start with a
Gaussian distribution which everyone
knows pretty much by heart it probably
wouldn't be necessary to remind you the
density of the probability distribution
but just to motivate the talk maybe this
picture might be quite important because
when you look over here is these are the
quantiles and on this axis we have
basically the range between the
quantiles
of the probability distribution so over
here this is the this is the probability
of 0.0015 this is this remaining tail
over here and over here there will be
just a very very tiny probability mass
left so we could basically squeeze
majority of the probability mass into
this picture what it means is that in
the in the world where gaussian law
lives the extreme events are not
happening really very often and pretty
much the tails of the distribution
decays exponentially but what if we move
to a different world we will move to the
world where things will be a bit more
awkward right we will have the
distribution which doesn't have first
finite moments which doesn't have second
finite movements whose tells will be the
king with the order to with the power
tool and if you look at this picture you
will see that not all point 15% of the
of the tail but 15% of the tail on this
picture is missing and that over here
not this tiny little little amount of
the mass is missing but five percent of
the mass is missing
we might consider other example because
there is never enough French
mathematician during one talk so in this
case we have a levy distribution and
before at least those first two
distributions which I have showed you
these have been symmetric this guy is
not symmetric at all if you look at this
picture the probability mass of this
distribution is located slowly on the
positive semi axis and if you look over
here there is a 30% of the tail missing
and this is the this is the purple
orbits which the tail is decaying but we
are still quite lucky because we
actually still have the density so we
would be asking like what has these
three distributions in common
is there something which they have in
common well if you would a little bit of
the of the math and play a little bit
with two densities you could derive this
particular property you could actually
figure out that you can scale them and
this is scaling this scaling property
over here that is that strong property
of the stable loss so if we think about
it a little bit differently because I
was saying that they are not very
user-friendly and so those of you who
doesn't like complex variable I have to
disappoint you complex variable is the
best way how to deal with this table
loss so so so let's take let's let's
let's take our densities into the three
era of Fourier domain or let's apply the
Fourier transform on them and and let's
take it into them into the complex world
and now you see that there is a bit more
bit more visible pattern but so over
here these cars will be real numbers and
over here there is doing some something
some imaginary number so we have here
some complex number so that is the
particular thing of the characteristic
functions because when the
characteristic function is
is a real it is the probability
distribution would be symmetric and when
the characteristic function function
that has imaginary part non-trivial so
in that case we have that asymmetry mass
of the probability distribution so we
can quite nicely write the probability
the characteristic function like this
and we would basically just want to have
the real part bounded such that we can
compute the we can invert the Fourier
transform and this is pretty much it but
there may be there may as there might be
a question and the question is we have
we have seen values 0.5 1 & 2 but can
the parameter alpha take other values
then then those 3 numbers so I mean if
it couldn't I wouldn't be standing here
so the answer is very simple
yes it can but there are some boundaries
and the boundaries is that the parameter
tends to take values between 0 & 2
and if they are at the level 2 it is the
Gaussian distribution which is the
limiting one and if they are at the
level 0 we are strongly bounded from the
0 because otherwise it wouldn't make
much sense and we would be just having
pretty much non random variables so
would be just a constant but let's think
about the things a little bit more from
a different view because there is a
particular thing which people like about
the Gaussian distribution and it is
mainly it's limiting the the fact that
it rises in the central limit theorems
why would you like central limit
theorems imagine you are doing lots of
experiments you're collecting your data
for your new machine learning algorithm
right and what would you like to do is
that these data are scattered all over
and the basic thing which you tend to do
would be a feature pre-processing and
you would like to transform your
variables so we would like to move them
in a certain way such that they would be
somehow
measurably located you would like to
because they might have different masses
they might be coming from the
distributions which are located in a
different
points so you try to standardize them so
you try to shoot their location and you
would also remove some kind of skills
which are in them such that you can
transfer them and dimensionless units so
the life is very simple if you can
compute their first and second moments
but what you would be doing if you can't
like in the case of the Gaussian
distribution so you can find some some
constants which can help you it can be
mean it can sir it can be median it can
be some truncated variance may be or you
might be just moving them in turpentine
the distribution so so you can play with
all sorts of things but the question is
what would be the properties is there
some kind of central limit theorem
existing for this kind of kind of
problems so anything about the simplest
convergence of the of the sums of the
random sums this is when you are drawing
the drawing the coin and you are trying
to figure out what is going to be the
number after a couple of after a couple
of toss coins and it's not really a
couple of toss coins it's a pretty large
number of the toss coins because you
would like to go with your toss coins to
infinity so if you just consider a
normalized random sums and you would
take the partial sums and one of the
basic central limit theorems will tell
you that the random variable to which
this sums will be converging will be a
normal distribution but there is
something a little bit stronger the
basic central limit theorem will tell
you that you don't really need to have
somehow
random variables coming from the same
distribution but you can they can
happily have different variances they
can even have different means it doesn't
matter what matters here is this
condition which can be reformulated and
you can know it as a feller condition or
whatever it be like these things in
mathematics but I believe not everyone
has the same kind of feelings as I do
for all sorts of integrals but the main
thing is
here that the tails are well behaved and
the tails are very nicely decaying and
if the tests are well behaved and they
are decaying what happens is that we
would end up with the normal
distribution but now let me challenge
you what happens if the tests are
misbehaving what happens in the case of
Cauchy distribution would there be some
kind of central limit theorem how would
you handle observations coming from this
distribution there is a good answer you
can handle them and you can handle them
such that the probability distribution
to which these observations will be
converging there will be there will
exist
Norman constants and the location
shifting constants such that you have in
the central limit theorem the classical
central limit theorems but at the same
time you will be having a limiting
distribution but because the tails are
misbehaving you have the heavy heavier
tails and you have the extreme evens
happening more often than in the in the
nice well-behaved world
the limiting distribution is really
going to be the Gaussian and sorry not
gained by the stable non Gaussian so at
this moment it is probably appropriate
to say what are the stable distributions
more more mathematically so it is all
about the sums so think about the sums
which we had so you have your random
number variables and you want to
approximate some kind of event so you
would sum to random the random variables
what is happening over here is think
about the normal distribution if you sum
up the random variables in the normal
distribution the sum is going to have
the same as going to keep the shape so
it is going to be still a shape of ice
Gaussian distribution it might be
shifted in the location its scale might
be different but the shape remains the
same if
you want to think about counter example
think about what happens if you sum up
exponential variables I think that in
that case the sum is going to have a
gamma distribution so here you see that
the property of the of the stability
isn't preserved but that is quite
precious property which allows you to
relax conditions when you are doing some
kind of mathematical modeling the nerman
constant there is is there is there is
there is a very nice theorem which you
can prove and I think that when I
started to work with the stable loss
like ten years ago I just like literally
a lot I read a feller volume too and I
think that that's the that's one of the
one of the very good books to read and
in general for the probability theory
but you can very nicely prove that the
nerman constant will look like this so
when you are having your estimates and
when you are working with the Gaussian
distribution this is just that square
square root of n which you would tend to
use everywhere right so but in the
gaussian case what you do is that you
just replace it with the fractional
power
so yeah the constant alpha is called the
parameter of the stability and you sort
of see why because if you sum up
gaussian and if you sum up Cauchy
distribution the property wouldn't be
preserved because you will be coming it
will be summing up distributions which
have different shapes but if you sum up
distributions coming with the same
stability property which means that that
decay of the tails really is the same
the property is being preserved there
might be some of you who enjoy physics
and who enjoy working with Markov
processes and who might like Markov
chains or whatever so the slide is just
to sort of make the point that the
stability property is basically
preserved even if you want to break this
Markov processes so if you
go from Gaussian distribution to the
Brownian motion you can go from Cauchy
distribution to the skosh coffee motion
and the stability property the scaling
property the nice scaling property which
you have in the Brownian motion it is
going to be preserved even in the case
when you relax the assumption that the
distribution has to be Gaussian but it
can be anything anything other coming
stable okay so yeah I'm very sorry but
we are there back again with the
characteristic functions now this is a
very general characteristic functions I
think mathematicians like this thing
which is called Levy processes so this
particular this particular measure and
the integral wouldn't have to have this
form it can be it can have other forms
and it would generate a different type
of processes but over here is the sort
of diffusion part and over here this is
a this is telling you if you will be
having a stochastic process this is
basically going to tell you about which
intensity the jumps are occurring so if
you have a Gaussian distribution there
is a lots of tiny little chumps if you
have a crochet crochet sort of coffee
flights you don't see that there will be
happening a big jumps and there might be
few very small increments but then you
will be having these big shots so
something like those of you who work in
finance it's probably it's so Cauchy
distribution wouldn't be probably the
best choice of the model but it's it it
would be having a bit more realistic
maybe shape the important thing here is
that particular is particularly for to
stay below you just can't mix Gaussian
and something different than Gaussian so
Cauchy and expected that you are going
to keep the stability property which is
basically something which you have seen
in the definition but you can prove it
too
anyway what is why this is important is
because if you work out to the integral
you will get to there
you will get to that particular thing
where things starts to get awkward and
maybe when you will look into the kippie
there and you will be looking into the
definition of the stable loss you will
find that page and that will show you
that the stable is defined like this
with this characteristic exponent this
is this is a sort of place very lots of
comedy of the mistakes starts because
when you look over here when we were
working out that integral the integral
on its own would be continuous in the
parameters in the parameter I'll find
the parameter beta and in the other
gamma and and lambda but and because
these functions when we work out the
integral they would be nicely continuous
but then we do some kind of awkward
algebraic manipulations just to have
this user-friendly forum which people
can nicely associate with and which in a
certain way is pretty helpful but what
we what had happened was that we
introduced a discontinuity and it's a it
comes with a price so just to quickly
summarize over here in the kernel we
have to we have to sort of specify if we
have alpha equal 1 so this would be
basically the cases when the Cauchy
distribution pair you would consider the
symmetric cases of the Cauchy
distribution the parameter beta is very
nice and user-friendly because it
controls the asymmetry and you know that
anything which has a beta equal to minus
1 is going to have maturity of the
probability mass located on the left
side of the real line and majority of
the probability must will be located on
the right side for case when beta is
close to 1 or equal 1 lambda is very
simple scaling parameter and the other
guy is just just shifts the things so I
think before I before I move to more
details or where the things gets tricky
I will sort of show you
type of distributions I have been
speaking about the whole time so this is
a case when alpha is nine one point nine
two seven so you might have a feeling
that is pretty much like well behaved
Gaussian distribution and you see that
when beta so here's our beta because
minus one here is beta one
so you see that the way how you can
shift the probability distribution you
don't have so much opportunity to shift
the probability mass so basically when
you are the closer you are getting two
Gaussian distribution the less
flexibility you have to move with the
distribution but let's consider other
example so this is when we would be
having alpha 1.9 so things starts to get
a bit more bit more open and here you
starts to have bit more flexibility so I
have to admit that when I used to work
with the financial time series I was
sort of always playing with the data
between region one point seven to
somewhere around one point 85 90
depending on the type of the indices or
on the type of the data and of course
you might not be very happy for the fact
that this distribution doesn't have a
second finite moment so usually just the
exponential truncation for the test
little bit helps but yeah you have there
the flexibility and the one point seven
is quite reasonable but okay usually
it's more fun when when you sort of 10
down to 1 because the distribution
starts to be a real fun so for 11.5 you
see that you can really start to shift
the probability mass this is the case
for 1.3 and this is 1.1 yeah and then
yeah I'm very sorry I don't have I don't
have pictures for below below 1 but what
happens what happens for the case for
below 1 is that
so in case when the lambda is between
one and two the probability distribution
is centered on the real line but when
the Alpha becomes smaller than one in
the extreme cases the probability
distribution will be located only on one
semi axis and in the second or in one of
the semi axis so sometimes when you like
to work with support then you like to
subordinate the Gaussian distribution so
this is very helpful thing which you can
use because if you have the extreme
distribution located only on the
positive part of the probability mass
you can very easily model the time
because sometimes we don't like when the
time flows backwards and our models and
it can also flow forwards but over here
it can flow only forwards when it's
located that was actually one of the
models which Mundell blood was using for
modeling time series I think it's
Mandelbrot Taylor model or something
like 1965 for and he wasn't actually
modeling at the time but he was modeling
the volume of the market I have a
feeling so he subordinated the Gaussian
distribution with the Alpha stable
located on the positive part okay so
what are the numerical issues which we
might be facing the numerical issues are
basically that the distributions are not
converging in Vitek parameters alpha and
beta and gamma they won't be converging
in this case to the Alpha which is going
to be equal to 1 it will actually
converge to the probability measure
which will explode so this is a big
source of the numerical inefficiencies
so whatever you would be working with
the stable loss and it would be like to
work in the regions which are close to
close to 1 there will be just just your
numerical methods will tend to break so
it's very good to look for these regions
there is a other parametrization which
is a sort of help and this
parameterization is it just corrects the
drift and if you correct if you little
bit shift the mass the log
raishin what happens is that at least
you will get the discontinuity gets
actually corrected but it comes with the
price because if you look at the drift
at the shift which we had to do here we
basically have to shift the parameter
alpha so as we are changing alpha we
also have to be moving the probability
mass so it doesn't it doesn't give you
any sort of nice statistical properties
but it is helpful for deriving numerical
methods so this is this would be the
transformation equations which you would
be having and yet so this is where it
becomes important because when you think
about alpha getting close to 1 you
really will be shifting the
distributions quite a lot in this
parameterization so the firm's of the
firm's of the stable densities we know
them in the closed form for the Gaussian
distribution cautious and clever as I
was saying at the beginning but it's the
life isn't so bad because there are
integral representations which are quite
good to implement and I was pretty much
working this majority of these
implementations
you can approximate them by series
expansions they work very well in the
Far regions or in the core regions but
all these things between is it's just
just yeah it's a I mean it's a it's
asymptotic series so they won't be
realized approximating it in the regions
for which they haven't been derived fast
Fourier transform has issues especially
if you are working in the region which
is a below for alpha below 1 because you
you need a lots of points and you will
have problems with stability especially
if the Alpha is becoming smaller the
Gibbs effect whether really kick on and
that tells will be oscillating so the
Fourier transform fast Fourier transform
will be working really well this is a
other parameterization which is pretty
helpful for deriving all these
Terrell's and all these sums which I was
talking about and well I would like to
give you a list of references which I
think are quite important especially
when it comes to the numerical
implementations so I think I can highly
recommend just this old textbook there
are all mathematical proofs and all the
relations to pretty much start with this
is a very good library and I I have to
say that I am great fan of the library
and hopefully I mean fingers crossed
that there will be represented around it
and it will be used in the sidebar
because that would be the best there is
that there is like a parallel
computation for the integrals so it's
nicely speed up and I think that area if
you are fans of C C++ is definitely
library to look into I would be very
careful about this particular paper and
this is quite funny because basically
this library is built on this paper and
many many implementations of the stable
O's are built on this paper but I I
think you need to test your methods if
you are using this paper so basically
any any library which you will be using
just test your methods and actually I
can highly recommend for unit tests
tables and graphs in this particular old
paper because I think that over here I
can pretty much associate with the
numbers which are over here and if it'll
be distinct it will realize that it is
different numbers than which you have in
this paper and which you have been all
those libraries so you can actually
maybe figure out how the earths are
propagating through the numerical
software so the tips this is the last
slide right so the tips for the
numerical implementations when you would
try to maybe play with these
distributions so because of all these
different parameterizations firstly just
pick up really pick up which of the
parameterization it is because often
people are thinking like this is this
this parameterization so it's going to
be these parameters but there are these
very very some transformation equations
and you will realize that just scaling
constant or locate
in constants day they can really make a
quite a big difference in the papers
there is just like lots of errors in the
papers propagating just due to this
effect
that's the implementation and this is
like if you if you just generate the
random samples and you will compute the
histogram and you will test your
numerical implant implementation of the
density against these estimated
histograms evil evil like sort of see
what I have been trying to suggest here
the other tricky bit here is that the
majority of the tests of the unit tests
in the software are carried for the
basic parameters because I mean you're I
think units that so what are you going
to write let's let's pick up the nice
numbers right but the trick comes vary
the numerical formulas are starting to
break so it is really good to test
exactly for these problematic regions
and like really just take the as fine
grain reality as you can and different
sort of numerical implementations and
yeah
you use different methods and undef
initely try to use this paper and well
good luck because I think it's pretty
much Mercer distributions to play with
Edgar thank you very much we have time
for one question and then we'll move on
to the news that was slightly wobbly
earlier I've got a question
Andrew how much he talked about adding
this work - soy pie how much of that
work the beside it was your work so
there is a big chunk of the code which
we've added on the github and shamefully
I think that because this big hunk of
this work actually I haven't been pushed
to because there was some competitive
part so but yeah I'm that's why I'm
saying like I'm not real enough about
the numerical methods which are being
used there and it really needs revision
and that's what I'm talking about it
just be learn how to work with the
distributions and sort of learn how to
correct it because it is a big shame
that they are not being used there are
people like Mandelbrot Oliver who played
with them and who spent all their lives
on trying to work with them so just yet
don't be stuck in and Gaussian
distribution and all the basic things
there's lots of nice scientific papers
to generate that out of that and
crucially when you talk about using it
and being wary of fur what's there you
talk about unit tests really what about
testing they're the code not just losing
it blindly which of course is terribly
sensible and we all write unit tests
because we're all very good engineers so
we'll move on to the news now I think
we're gonna give a double round of
applause to Andrea because not only is
she presenting something but also she's
contributing to our ecosystem
you